[Music]
standing in front of this dazzling
russian church you will be amazed by its
colorful architecture and history the
church of the savior unspilled blood has
been a memorial a morgue and a warehouse
for potatoes
[Music]
known for the colorful onion-shaped
domes that dot the saint petersburg
skyline the church of the savior
unspilled blood was erected on the spot
of emperor alexander ii assassination in
1881.
inside the church 7
500 square meters of mosaics an
abundance of italian marble and a
variety of russian precious stones
decorate the walls and ceilings
the construction of the church took 24
years costing over 4.6 million rubles
it was closed for services in the 1930s
when the bolsheviks went on an offensive
against religion during the second world
war the church was used as a temporary
morgue and after the war it was used for
vegetable storage earning it the comical
name savior of potatoes this dazzling
russian church is home to some of
europe's most colorful architecture and
history
[Music]
it can be
beetles that come off a cactus it can be
the dried urine of a cow
little insects that grow on an oak tree
a chunk of lead that's soaked in vinegar
it's truly amazing
we're in harvard university outside the
forbes pigment collection
pigment is a very small particle of
coloured material that is mixed in with
a binding medium
the pigment gives paint its colour
the forbes pigment collection has been
brought together over several decades we
have around 2500 pigments
[Music]
we have a lot of very unusual and very
rare colors
so this is i think one of the more
unusually named pigments it's called
dragon's blood
it doesn't come from dragons it comes
from rattan palms and it gives a very
bright red pigment
the unusual aspect of mummy has to do
with its source rather than the color
itself
and that comes from egyptian mummies
and it's the resin that's applied to the
outside of the bandages
i think the rarest color that we have is
actually a
an entire ball of indian yellow and this
is a pigment that is made from the dried
urine of cows that are fed only on mango
leaves
if you're looking at a work of art and
you want to understand
what
is original and what's a restoration you
will take a tiny sample of pigment and
analyze it
a lot of the pigments are actually toxic
so you don't want to handle the pigments
and then go out to lunch there's a green
called emerald green that has an arsenic
center to it
we can use them for telling if something
is real or not people will say this is
by a certain artist
and we can look at the materials that
are used
and decide if those materials were
available during that artist's lifetime
if not then we have to look at who might
have painted that picture
i can't pick a personal favorite it's
like asking to pick a favorite child
no the other 2400 would feel left out
it's like my world is
washed out and i see fewer shades of
color than most people do
so normal people see a million colors i
may see as many as a hundred million
[Music]
my name is wendy i'm a producer at cnn
and i am colorblind
my name is maureen seberg i'm a
tetrachromat and i'm an author
tetrachromacy
is the presence of a fourth cone class
in your
retina i keep naming my invisible colors
maybe i'll have my own crayola box one
day
when i was in kindergarten my teacher
called my parents because i was coloring
the leaves of my trees and the trunks of
my trees the same color because i
couldn't really see the difference
between green and brown the only time it
was ever overwhelming
is a paint contractor came to my house
and brought no fewer than 32 samples
before i was satisfied that it was a
true beige
when i pick out clothes
that's hard
i have been known to buy the outfit that
the mannequin is wearing because i know
that that goes together you don't want
to go clothing shopping with me because
the sales people tell me but it matches
and i can only look at them
sympathetically and keep looking
um i never think like oh if i weren't
colorblind it would be so much easier to
get dressed in the morning it's just
it's kind of part of me i guess i'm a
unicorn or something
[Music]
this bright colorful temple located in
southern india wasn't put on earth just
to catch the eye
it's also one of the largest hindu
houses of worship
welcome to the shari ranganathi swami
temple
[Music]
it is dedicated to the hindu god of
ranganatha a reclining form of the hindu
deity visnu
but this relaxed looking god is one of
the highest levels of hindu idols
the temple which has over 6 miles of
walls and over a hundred buildings is
one of the five important pilgrimage
sites along the river kaveri for
devotees of ranganatha
the temple itself is a beacon of the
uniquely south indian dravidian style of
architecture
its temples are adorned with
pyramid-shaped towers made from
sandstone soapstone or granite
the first construction on this site
dates back nearly 700 years
it grew and grew into the wonder that it
is today
a site that will surely settle any
pilgrims wandering soul
[Music]
at first glance visitors may not realize
that inside this mosque is a
multicolored secret
[Music]
located in iran the nazir al-mukh mosque
is commonly known as the pink mosque due
to the rose-colored tiles that cover the
interior however this is far from the
only color found inside
a wall of stained glass windows turns
the interior into a rainbow wonderland
[Music]
built in 1888 the mosque took 12 years
to complete
nasir almaq features plenty of
traditional islamic architecture
elements such as the arches and the
central structure however the presence
of stained glass windows a design
element relatively rare for mosques
makes this particular mosque a unique
and stunning sight to see
the stained glass in nasiromoc was built
to catch the morning sunlight as it
reflects off the walls and the brightly
colored persian rugs on the floor
[Music]
the hope and intention was for the
colors to create a peaceful atmosphere
during early morning prayer
[Music]
the nasir almaq mosque has become as
much of a destination for visitors
seeking the perfect photo as those who
still worship under the rainbow of light
[Music]
this colorful spot has a dark past
las pamitas was once a dangerous place
with clashes between rival gangs
but the city government launched and
funded a project called pachuca paints
itself to turn the community around
[Music]
the painting itself involved
participation from all of the households
[Music]
they painted over 200 houses using 5000
gallons of paint
[Music]
these individually painted houses
combined to make one beautiful rainbow
design
inspired by pachooka's nickname la baya
rosa or the beautiful breezy city
the aim of the project was to bring a
sense of liveliness and livability back
to the city
the ministry of planning and evaluation
of the city of pachuca has noted that
the crime rate in the city has decreased
since the mural was painted
[Music]
this is rainbow
a red sided eclectus parish
that deep green plumage with a tint of
blue signifies that rainbow is a male
bird
female eclectuses have deep red feathers
and until the 20th century males and
females were considered different
species
native to papua new guinea these
beautiful birds nest high up in the
tropical rainforests
they are considered to be extremely
intelligent birds and amongst the best
in talking ability for parrots
their vocal skills and stunning plumage
have made them highly desirable in the
pet trade
while logging and other forms of habitat
destruction have caused their population
to decline steadily
this is the red-sided eclectus parrot